hi everyone and welcome back to my
channel today I am channeling my inner
Newton by sitting here under a passion
fruit vine and I'm going to be looking
through something that actually really
excites me and that is Newton's great
work it is in Latin the philosophy
naturalis principia mathematica or
translated to english the mathematical
principles of natural philosophy so this
is a super important book to the history
of science it is where we were
introduced to Newton's laws you know
talking about motion things like the
inverse square law you know
laws of gravity that keep large bodies
in orbit and some really nice insights
just about the physical world so this
was first published in 1687 although
this version here is not own original it
is since being translated into English
by Andrew macht and then revised by
Florian Kaduri so that's a copy that I
have here and in this video we're just
going to be taking a look through this
book and having a look at some of these
key insights and at some of the science
in the way that it was first presented
to us the writing of this book kind of
came about after Newton was visited by
his friend Edmund Halley after Halley's
Comet frame and Halley wanted to know
from Newton you know what are your
thoughts on you know what motion
heavenly bodies would follow if they're
governed by this invest square law that
they were starting to think about and
Newton said you know I've already worked
it out they're going in ellipses and
I'll send you my calculations so in
writing up you know all of his thoughts
and calculations around that it
eventually evolved into this book which
ended up laying kind of a foundation for
classical mechanics that we still learn
and use today it apparently took Newton
about one-and-a-half years of solid
focused work to work on this manuscript
and get it out there he had to put some
of his side interests like alchemy on
hold for a little bit
to get this out and we're very glad that
he did it's very important and I'm
really excited to have a look at it so
let's see what's inside so here it is
the book which helps to bring the tools
of mathematics to physics and help to
bring us a really great period of
science the book starts off with a page
of definitions where Newton is defining
things like mass momentum inertia and
centripetal force these just set up the
rest of the book and then we go into the
axioms or laws of motion now these are
arguably the most famous aspects of this
book and these are Newton's laws one two
and three listed here and these are
still laws that you would learn about in
any physics class or a lecture today and
they're still very useful and relevant
now we'll come back to reading through
some of these laws to see how Newton
laid them out I will come back to that
in a minute but we'll just have a look
at what's in the rest of this book so
after the axioms and explaining them a
bit we get on to book one of three in
this work which is the motion of bodies
now that's pretty much what it sounds
like it's you know how things move and
how you can describe the motion of
pretty much everything although in this
first book we're only talking about the
motion of bodies moving through free
space you know there's no resisting
medium and that leads us into what book
two is about which is the motion of
bodies in resisting mediums so I guess
you have a little bit more to consider
here and yet he really talks about every
case that you can think of when you want
to know about motion there's also plenty
of diagrams and mathematical
explanations which I guess are good
because the language in this book I must
can be a little confusing at the best of
times you know it was originally written
in Latin and it's been translated to
English here but even then I find it
very difficult sometimes to figure out
what's going on and what they actually
you referring to so maybe the diagrams
do actually help out quite a bit now
there is actually a third book which I
don't have included here in my copy
which is on the system of the world and
it's more about astronomy and applying
these concepts of motion to astronomy
but since I don't have that one here
we're just going to be talking about
books 1 & 2 so I've taken us back to the
definitions page just to have a little
read of some of these to see what the
language is like so for the first
definition here it's actually talking
about mass and he says the quantity of
matter is the measure of the same
arising from its density and old
conjointly now this language about the
measure of the same could actually be
read as the quantity of matter is the
measure of matter arising from its
density and bulk conjointly which to me
makes a little bit more sense when you
read it that way
so that's mass and then we have another
definition here it reads in a very
similar way the quantity of motion is
the measure of the same arising from the
velocity and quantity of matter
conjointly so that there is actually
talking about momentum so you'll still
see the definition of momentum given in
textbooks everywhere as usually P for
momentum is equal to mV
which is meta and velocity so nothing
has really changed there in physics we
then go on to talk about what is
actually inertia or as it's called here
an innate force of matter it is a power
of resisting by which everybody as much
as in it lies continues in its present
state whether it be of rest or of moving
uniformly forwards and a rights line so
that's just talking about inertia we
haven't got onto any of Newton's laws
yet these are just setting up
definitions for what we're going to go
and talk about so we've got some other
things like an impressed force or a
centripetal force there's also quite a
lengthy discussion at the end of these
definitions where a Newton splits up the
definition of centripetal force into its
absolute quantity its accelerative
quantity and its motive quantity and
then has a bit of a long-winded
discussion here about what is absolute
true and mathematical time or the same
with you know absolute true and
mathematical space or motion and I think
he's just trying to clear up confusion
about I guess what exact properties he
is referring to for the rest of the book
so yeah this is a pretty long section
here which I'll admit is not the easiest
to follow but we get to this page our
laws of motion let's see if you can
recognize these laws for number one we
have that every body continues in its
state of rest or a uniform motion in a
right line unless it is compelled to
change that state by forces and pressed
upon it so yeah that actually makes
sense and there's just a little
explanation here and then we have law
too so the change of motion is
proportional to the motive force
impressed and is made in the direction
of the right line and which that force
is impressed now I believe this second
law could be written in a more familiar
way as F is equal to MA so a super
important equation in physics I guess
this is it written out and it's a
long-winded original form but you know
that's actually kind
a revolutionary law because it is so
useful in so many areas of physics and
it's neat to see you know need Newton
talking about it and sort of his own
words here so law number three it's also
might be a little familiar for you it is
that too every action there is always
opposed an equal reaction or the mutual
actions of two bodies upon each other
are always equal and directed to
contrary paths and again I think that
one's not too hard to understand
especially if you've seen it recently in
your own classroom so yeah then we just
have a few corollary x' Newton you know
giving some little bits of evidence or
justification for his reasoning here but
we won't go through all of those now
we'll just go to the start of book one
so book one starts with a mathematical
look at something called the method of
first and last ratios which to my
understanding is like a geometrical form
of infinitesimal calculus so even though
I believe Newton had already come up
with his sort of you know version of
calculus as we know today by the time he
wrote this book he doesn't feature
calculus in here and instead publishes
calculus at a much later time now
whether he did that to make you know
these proofs and things more
understandable to other scientists and
physicists at the time I'm not sure or
maybe he just wasn't ready to share some
of his other you know theories and
workings as of yet but anyway he he
proves a lot of these things very
geometrically and it's pretty impressive
and interesting to just have a look at
how some of these things are done so
this is you know a mathematical
discussion here
and then we get into section 2 of book 1
which says here the determination of
centripetal forces so a lot of these
first few propositions is talking about
the relationship between centripetal
forces and things like areas or you know
circular motion and the radius of a path
that would be traveled so these actually
relate to what we now know as Kepler's
laws and Kepler did actually come before
Newton so I think that Newton is
building on some of those laws from
Kepler here in the section as we move
through two propositions five to ten we
start to hear about the inverse square
law which you know says that centrifugal
force varies as the inverse square of
the distance to the center now I think
it comes up here in proposition six we
see it just mentioned at the end here
that the centripetal force in the middle
of an arc will be directly as the verse
sine and inversely as the square of the
time and we've got a little semicircle
diagram down here now it's a little bit
hard to understand there but you
probably have encountered an inverse
square law in a more familiar way as
written like one over R squared and lots
of things like you know in this case we
could be talking about you know a
gravitational attraction varying in
strength as an inverse square law so the
further away from it you get it drops
off quite steeply and because it's the
inverse of the square so that's kind of
what we're talking about in this section
here and basically we just get a lot of
stuff about elliptical orbits the motion
of you know planets or other bodies we
get lots of things about centripetal
force
and I think I'll just have a little skip
through the rest of these so coming to
book 2 the first section of it talks
about the motion of bodies that are
resisted in the ratio of the velocity so
you know resistance that is in direct
proportion to velocity which is not an
alien concept to any physicist nowadays
so we talk about that a bit through some
more propositions and some more
geometrical arguments section two here
then goes on to talk about the motion of
bodies that are resisted as the square
of their velocities we have a few more
sections here before we get on to
section 5 which is hydrostatics
essentially the density and compression
of fluids so that's pretty cool we're
even talking about fluid dynamics here
and then for the next section which is
section 6 we get the motion and
resistance of pendulous bodies so that
is the effects of air resistance on
pendulums and I think that Newton did a
lot of experiments so did other
physicists at the time with pendulums so
it makes sense that they get their own
little sections so yeah that's pretty
interesting that he was able to look at
resistance and pendulums and you can see
that through his diagrams here like this
is all really impressive stuff and I'm
quite excited to see it laid out because
I've never really seen it laid out in
the way it was initially presented
before now one important aspect of this
book and it's stressed by Newton and
like at the start and and through a lot
of the language is that he's for example
with all of his work about gravitation
he's not trying to provide any
explanations or reasoning as to you know
how gravity works and why you know
bodies attract each other
gravitationally he he doesn't you know
give an explanation and he doesn't try
to give an X
the notion of that so there is sort of a
famous quote from Newton and it came at
the end of book 3 and this work where he
essentially says I found no hypotheses
so there he says he's not claiming to to
really have any understanding of how
gravity works and I guess you could
argue we still don't really know how go
but he works but here in this book
Newton is doing his best to show you the
effects of it and how it will affect
motion and how things will move under it
so I think I'm going to leave my little
review of the book here but because I
was so excited to get a copy of this
book and to wade through it I'm going to
upload another video hopefully tomorrow
where I'm just going to read the book
and nothing else so I'll see how far I
can get through it without getting too
tired but maybe you can watch that if
you want to maybe you know put into your
subconscious some of Newton's words and
some of those phrasing or you just want
to you know hear more about this
language so thanks for watching this
video I hope you found it a little bit
interesting and I'll see you next time
[Music]